How long have you been in a cult?
What's it like to be a Chia human?
You look like you could
stick your finger in a socket
without having stuck
your finger in a socket.
(upbeat music)
I volunteered to let a comedian heckle me
all day tomorrow.
He's gonna come to my house.
He's gonna wake me up.
He's gonna spend all day with me.
I'm kinda looking forward
to it 'cause I like company,
but I also feel like it
might get really annoying,
especially if his jokes are bad.
My name is J. Chris Newberg
and I've been a comedian
for 18 years.
Throughout my career, I've
been heckled from time to time,
but I've never had the joy and pleasure
of heckling someone back.
I volunteered to do this
because I think I have really
thick skin and I like good comedy.
I imagine he'll just be
like, observing what I do
and making fun of it.
I can't imagine it could
get that personal because
how would he know anything about me?
I've never met this guy.
I've done some extensive
research on Jordan.
I've looked online at his
Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter profiles.
I've talked to his friends.
I've talked to his coworkers.
I've talked to his ex-girlfriend.
I'm comin' at him.
I'm not really sure how I'm going to feel,
'cause I hate everything
hecklers represent.
I'm gonna try to be mean,
but I'm not a mean person.
But, fuck him.
It's 7:53 in the morning.
I found Jordan's place.
I'm with Kelly.
She's a producer at Buzzfeed.
She's gonna be followin' me.
We're outside
his apartment.
It's pretty good so far.
It's uh, pretty dirty.
I don't understand the
science of this decor.
Like, what girl doesn't come in here,
see this,
and then just leap right off the balcony?
Here's Jordan killing it,
from when he played a young Carrot Top.
I wonder which one of those
socks are his girlfriend.
- [Jordan] Hello.
Hey buddy.
(laughs) Super excited to be here
with the third baseman of
the Los Angeles Dodgers.
Dude, I don't even know
who the third baseman is
of the Los Angeles Dodgers.
Look in the mirror, buddy.
So, what's it like to be
the body double for sadness?
People do say I have resting sad face.
So, I heard you and your
girlfriend just broke up.
True.
Good for her.
Damn, getting some--
Gettin' deep.
Yeah, and you're
putting on your girlfriends.
What?
You'll understand later.
How long have you played
bass for Mumford and Sons?
You're flossing on the day that
you're going to the dentist.
Isn't that like cleaning
your house before you have
a cleaning lady come over?
Which, obviously, has never happened.
So, you're putting product in right now?
Mmhmm.
That's cool.
How long have you been a before model?
You're like the most handsome
of all the Keebler elves.
We're going to the dentist.
You're gonna let him drill ya?
Well, hopefully not.
(playful music)
Hopefully, I won't need any drillings.
Maybe just some poking.
Minimal poking, hopefully.
That's cool.
That was my nickname in high school.
Do you find that you're
on Tinder most of the time
during sex?
What are your favorite dating apps?
Tinder is the tried and true.
What's your opening
line usually, on Tinder?
I don't use repeat opening lines
'cause I think that's insincere.
I use their profiles to
come up with opening lines.
What was your favorite
that you've ever used?
Oh man, I had a really good one recently.
It didn't get a response
and I was bummed about it.
Her profile just said I like
people, places, and things.
And, I said, what you
got against adjectives?
They probably have very nice
things to say about you.
I thought that was pretty good.
It's weird that that
didn't get a response.
So, do you still talk to Harry Potter?
Do you get sad when some
of your personalities
won't talk to you?
Would you fuck yourself for money?
A-ha-ha-ha-ha, you suck at parking.
So, I've got my first
break from getting heckled,
and so far he hasn't gotten under my skin.
Nice guy, I like him.
- [J. Chris] Any final
words before they tell you
that you have nine cavities?
I'm really hopin' they don't tell me that.
You're doing so good, Jordan.
(instrument motor running)
Hopefully, they'll give you
a little plaque.
What'd you have for lunch?
I had like a chicken pita thing.
It's so hard to be mean to you.
It's just so hard, because everything
that you do is just nice.
Like, there's nothing weird about
having a chicken pita for lunch.
I'm at Jordan's desk now at Buzzfeed.
So, seriously, what happens in the finale
of Game of Thrones?
Dude, you know we're not
allowed to talk about that.
I'm here also with Destiny,
his desk neighbor.
What's it like bein'
around Jordan all day?
He's a great guy.
Really nice, really quiet.
Kinda sits to himself.
No, I said Jordan.
Gettin' ready to go down to
the Laugh Factory from The Den.
Gonna get on stage and do some jokes,
and Jordan is gonna heckle me
like I've heckled him all day.
Hey, what's up.
How's is goin'?
I'm in pretty good shape.
I'm in really good spirits.
I've lost a lot of weight,
ever since I quit--
Is that the shirt you picked?
(playful music)
Did you just pick up the
first t-shirt off the floor
that you'd already worn like three times,
and decide, that's the shirt for my set?
(playful music)
Uh, yes, actually.
That's what I did.
I decided that.
I asked this girl out once,
and she was like, all right, cool.
But, I want you to know
one thing: I'm in AA.
I was like, all right, that's cool,
then you can drive,
'cause I'm gonna get hammered.
I bet she still didn't text you back.
Do you ever notice that
sitting down and standing up
sounds a lot like sex?
'Cause you're always like,
oh my god!
It makes sense that you have
no idea what sex sounds like.
Aren't you sitting in a booth alone?
Yeah.
I just childproofed my house,
and by that I mean I purchased condoms.
Tell a funny joke.
(playful music)
You're all about not
laughing at your shit joke?
(laughing)
- [Kelly] So, do you guys feel closer now?
I definitely think that he
should answer that first.
Because he knew all these things about me,
and was sort of like digging at them,
I felt like a certain closeness.
Like, oh this person knows me,
and then, throughout the day
spending the day together,
I felt like we sort of
had a mutual understanding
that we're both going through
this experience together.
I think the most frustrating thing
about heckling a nice guy is,
you kinda feel like an a-hole,
because you don't really mean it.
It's like, here's this nice person,
who's just going about their day,
and they're at the dentist
and I'm like a-ha, you suck!
I would definitely hang out with you
in real life.
Yeah.
I think that'd be fun.
I would do it as long as I didn't have to
come to your apartment.
(rock music)
(whipping and creaking)